these men are learning how to install
heating they hope their training will
eventually help them to find a job in a
German company I think their future
bosses could be sitting here waiting to
greet Chancellor Angela Merkel before
going on the political offensive she
came here to rally support from industry
leaders for her refugee policy this
began says that I'm convinced that we
can't overcome this challenge at the
german austrian border in germany we
must do what we can no question about it
but if we think too small on the issue I
think too much about ourselves it puts
Europe at risk these Vida and it was
that's why I'm very thankful to you we
need a europe-wide approach Pearson ends
as Paul lr get that's while German
business leaders are willing to pull
their weight they're also keen to stress
that there'll be no quick fixes to the
crisis de origen alicia Dreman industry
is prepared to do its part for
integration but I'd like to caution
against inflated expectations you can't
bypass qualifications and language
skills the needs of the German labor
market can't be designed according to
one's wishes the aim is to integrate as
many refugees into the jobs market the
faster the better there are currently
six hundred thousand job vacancies
excellent work dolls and often a stone
but for many people arriving in Germany
that jobs market is still far out of
reach many asylum seekers hope taking
classes will help them find work once
their cases have been processed